LaDainian Tomlinson the hall-of-famer
NFL Network analyst is in El Paso Texas
Kellogg's Frosted Flakes mission Tiger
and Dick's Sporting Goods foundation
giving middle school kids access to
school sports and teaming up with Tony
the Tiger to give every kid and El Paso
the chance to play more on this mission
Tiger dot-com
good morning LT how are you good morning
Dan and and I'll tell you that was that
was well said that was well everybody
thank you thank you good to talk to you
I'll talk to you soon yeah hey I just
saw this article and it had a comment
from Earl Thomas saying the NFL needs to
protect Lamar Jackson a little better
than what they are I don't know if
there's been anything that stood out
with you so far where you said boy
somebody's going above and beyond the
call of duty to try to go at Lamar
Jackson's legs so what do you make of
this comment by Errol Thomas I think
girl is just kind of you know he's being
a great teammate and and just kind of
putting it out there that hey you know
watch out for for things that might
become and I agree with you I haven't
seen anything malicious that people are
trying to go out to his legs are
intentionally hurting you know but I
think Earl is just putting a bug and
everyone's ear the last year that as we
get closer to the playoffs and things
you know are hiding you know
the playoffs wins are on the line
championships on the line watch out for
people trying to print him out the game
yeah but it's hard to be if you're a
defensive player like when does he
become a runner and he's not a
quarterback any longer and then if he is
a runner I should be able to go at him
the way defenses went at you
I completely agree once he once he
leaves that pocket and he tucks that
ball you know he is a runner
he's like a running back and so you have
to attack him and get him down to the
ground you know the best way you can and
if that's going at his legs to grab a
leg to hold him to keep it down that's
what you have to do
and certainly when he's in the pocket
then you know he should get the same
respect as every other quarterback in
the pocket but you know once he tossed
their football is it all for again how
many yards do you think he could
actually run for if he wanted to oh man
that's a good question this offense is
built around him you know so he probably
can put up you know thirteen to fifteen
hundred yards because his office is
built around them and he runs the ball
so much you know and I just think about
a guy like Michael Vick you know he had
over a thousand yards and he didn't have
often scattered around he'll you know he
is yours came from scrambling around so
I think because the offense is built
around him he probably can max I would
say 1,500 yards yeah and you had the
design place it's not like he's gonna
line up in the backfield because that's
different that's when everybody knows
you're getting the ball now he still has
that element of surprise but I think
what's overlooked with Lamar Jackson is
his ability to throw from the pocket LT
because we tend to look at him as a
running quarterback who can throw
instead of a throwing quarterback who
can run and we thought that maybe he was
a project that maybe it was going to
take some time here and I think that's
that's been overlooked with him is his
ability you know just to throw from the
pocket it really has been your ride has
been overloaded and you know I believe
that's where he has made the most dry
set is throwing the football when you
think about last year when he took over
and they went on the Levon to get to the
playoffs when he played the Chargers in
LA the charge has had a difficult time
stopping that often is with him because
they just have haven't seen it before no
one had but in the playoffs where they
made their you know strides that was
forcing him to throw the football and
you know he struggle at that time I
don't think you could do that anymore to
Lamar Jackson because he can't beat you
from the pocket I think what you have to
do is make him throw the ball on the
perimeter
can throw it outside the numbers you
know taking out of the middle of the
field from him because when you look at
it that's where he's getting most of his
yards through the airs those tight ends
running up too soon yeah I agree with
you I got a making throw from the pocket
but I also have to make him throw wide
because he loves the middle of the field
he loves his tight ends and if you're
able to do that then like I got to take
away one of his weapons because he's
always going to have another one but
that's why he's the MVP we're talking
two LaDainian Tomlinson and the Hall of
Famer do you consider the Patriots
cheaters no I mean I don't consider them
tears I really dodge not I do believe
that in the past they have done some
questionable things no by honestly Dan
well I think a lot of teams try to push
the envelope you know a lot of teams try
to go overboard I think the Patriots
happened because they have done it so
much they got caught in some situations
I do believe that this situation I don't
think Bill Belichick has anything to do
with it
I really don't and so you know you know
I mean bill came out and said and he
said have we pushed the envelope have we
you know been on the verge of going too
far sure we have you know but in this
situation I have no knowledge of it we
have nothing to do it than that and I
believe Dallas Cowboys face the LA Rams
these are you know the Rams have to win
they have to win out if they're gonna
make the playoffs
whereas Dallas could still lose and
still end up winning the NFC East which
team do you have a harder time trying to
figure out this season topic without
question is the Cowboys you know Cowboys
are the most talented team there's also
the most frustrating team to watch
because all that talent in humans you
don't understand why they're not winning
more than they are whether or not
beating teams 500 are better you know
with the Rams it you know for me they
just got away from what made them good
you know they were trying to manage
todd gurley and you know preserve him
and all this stuff at the beginning of
year now it's too late I don't think
they're going to get into the playoffs I
think they're too far behind men they're
trying to get a ball to Tiger Lee and
they look great now but it's too late
too little too late for me the cowboy I
don't know what which team is going to
show up from week to week you sold on
dak Prescott as a franchise quarterback
I am okay I think Derrick is a franchise
quarterback he's shown me enough over
these last few years of his development
now we're still talking about Zack is
still a young guy you know so he's going
to continue to develop into more of a
franchise guy but he had done more you
know he has done enough to me to warrant
the Dallas Cowboys you know what doc you
you are God going forward you are
franchise quarterback because I think
that at this point he can win games on
his own like he doesn't mean the running
game any longer where you know years
past he needed to rock out I think he
has enough talent around him that he can
win games on his arm it's being the head
coach of the Dallas Cowboys still a
coveted jump absolutely I mean I think
it is because of the brand you know
there is going to be some hesitation
because of the relationship that Jerry
Jones has you know with everyone in the
organization and the players and you
know what are the owner ask you know
what three radio shows or so yeah but I
don't want my owner to have radio shows
LT I want him seen not heard that's part
of the problem I'd you know be up in the
skybox with a drink in your hand and
that's fine but I don't I don't want you
so involved and I think that's if Urban
Meyer is truly interested in this which
is what I was told yesterday that he is
interested in the Dallas job there's no
way I'd go in there without you know
some ground rules laid down here well
without question if you're someone like
Urban Meyer who deserves to be able to
run the team speak for the team
you know Jerry has to be able to remove
himself he asked you can't be can't be
urban mom he can't do it but say but say
if it was somebody like Lincoln Raleigh
Lincoln Ronald little knew he would be a
new NFL coach he I don't think he would
care you know he's so happy to be the
Dallas Cowboys head coach that he's
going to overlook a lot of that stuff
initially so that's why I say the brand
of being a Dallas Cowboys coach having
that on your resume dance I mean that's
huge for a coach were you or like were
you Cowboys fan growing up absolutely
yes I was did you meet Emmett I did meet
I did meet him right when I was 12 years
old that in it did you nervous were you
well it was Jay Novacek football camp so
initially I was really nervous but you
know afterimage said a couple of words
to me man I was just coming in awe and
so like you know like can't believe I'm
looking at him it's midnight otherwise
this guy you know and so the nerves went
away and I just kind of just watched a
guy you know just kind of cool
experience that's pretty cool pretty
cool hey you're doing great things down
there in El Paso once again it's the
Kellogg's Frosted Flakes
mission Tiger Dick's Sporting Goods
foundation giving middle school kids
their access to school sports and you
can learn a lot more about this LT
teaming up with Tony the Tiger to give
every kid in El Paso the chance to play
you can learn more at mission Tiger
dot-com it's always great to talk to you
we appreciate your time LT thank you
that's LaDainian Tomlinson for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]